Republicans are working very hard to
defend President Trump this is the
latest some Republicans this is true are
saying that President Trump didn't
commit an impeachable crime because he's
not smart enough that's a real thing
they're saying they're saying it could
have done because he's not smart enough
then Bill Clinton said trust me an
impeachable crime does not have to
involve a brain yeah let's say
bipartisan joke there's something there
for everyone John Legend was named
People magazine's sexiest man alive this
man alive yeah when they heard this baby
boomer said who's John Legend while
Millennials said what's a magazine
the company that makes Twinkies is
making a Twinkie cereal yeah
Twinkie cereal yeah it's perfect for
people who don't want to wait until noon
to get gout as I said people everywhere
in the country talking about the
appeasement hearings millions of people
watch the testimony yesterday including
myself I watched it I don't recognize
all the politicians and while I was
watching I didn't know who everyone was
so I was very glad the networks provided
information sidebars to tell me who was
speaking it was so helpful like this one
they put up with congressman Jackie
Speier it lists just all the different
things that she's done and who she is in
case you don't know and I find that very
very helpful but I did want to mention
this as the hearings continued and went
on the stats they put up became less
useful they really did yeah I was think
you'll see what I mean for example GOP
attorney Steve Castor's right here it
says answers to the name fuzz nuts look
at this
entire head can fit neatly into
Christmas stocking appeared in an
episode of Law & Order as skinny snitch
number 2 yeah
helping me helping you
representative Chris Stewart in yeah it
says right here divorced his eyebrows in
2007 gets his hair cut by an undertaker
lost his virginity to the song here a
grand old one representative Adam Schiff
yeah audition to be advil space of
migraine headache to lays climax for
reciting pie out loud one of his parents
is a balloon there's this one
representative Mike Quigley yeah turns
out floss on Halloween wears a bike
helmet when he drives first result when
you do a Google image search for
disappointed dad and finally
representative Danny heck yeah
finds mayonnaise a bit - zesty came to
life when some kids put a pair of
magical hi glasses on a potato calls
directions God batons
you